we were talking earlier about your your
marriage your partner
uh mary you guys have been together 25
years now
together 27 yeah 27 married 25
okay that's true i forget i've been
married
19 together 21. um
and uh a couple of years yeah i always
forget that you're supposed to add in
yes you were with this person for two
years before that why aren't you
including that
and so i i've learned i've got to add
that in so yeah
but that's very impressive what do you
think is the secret to keeping
uh this relationship going
oh gosh i don't know um
telling the truth yeah uh and laughter
yeah um yeah i mean you work
at it but we we kind of made this deal
early on
uh we both have been married before and
been in relationships and
we we both before we met each other
right before
we're basically saying to ourselves well
we're just not cut out
to be in a relationship i can mess up
anything and da da
so um it's kind of miraculous that we
found each other but we both
kind of felt like we don't want too much
drama
yeah in our life you know we'll do hard
stuff and we've done
we've had four teenagers and three grand
kids in
life you know life comes at you and so
there's
there is hard stuff right by and large
we kind of went you know let's do
let's do 93 joyous
fun together and we'll do seven percent
really hard
yeah and we we tend to
do that that's a good that's a good
formula i like i
similar i think to what you're saying i
have found it helps that
my wife and i we both find ourselves
ridiculous you know that there's we
don't we don't take ourselves that
seriously and to me that feels like that
is the
that is the oil that sort of keeps the
gears moving
is that and and also i mean she thinks
i'm absurd
and doesn't take me too seriously and i
think like okay good mary has used those
exact words
she finds me ridiculous
look to be fair i you are you're no no
i know but it's great joy for me too i'm
not defensive about ridiculous and
shallow and all of those things it
brings me a lot of happiness so please
have at me
i enjoy it myself